yes they've gone even further left than
her the new mayor of Chicago is a guy by
the name of Brandon Johnson he used to
be a teacher uh here were some of his
policies while he was teaching
it taught me though was
pushing like to eliminate sort of the
standardization of our Public Schools my
students sometimes would get frustrated
I didn't offer any test prep many of my
other colleagues were doing it at the
time I was pushing our Administration to
move away from that
to be quite Frank with you I didn't
issue a lot of homework for students
that was my own way of sort of rebelling
against the structure
um I I don't think I ever gave a kid an
F
I just I don't I don't know how a
student sits in front of you and fail I
mean there's so much there so no test
prep
guys there's a test tomorrow I can't
tell you anything about it I have no
freaking clue what's going to be on that
thing good luck with all of that that's
one thing he didn't do much homework in
his defense I always felt there was too
much homework in high school I guess
that was a little debatable I'm trying
to be fair here and he didn't give
anyone an F
these people they there is no bottom to
this hold do you guys get that like what
he's saying there is I wouldn't want a
kid to think that he's an idiot but some
kids are idiots and you know what you do
you give them an f and then you know
what happens they then might go you know
I don't like being left back a year or I
don't like being made fun of by my
friends or I don't like being dumb and
then they might start working harder so
you might go to this guy all right all
right
he doesn't want to tell the kids what's
on the test he doesn't want to give them
much homework he doesn't want to give
apps now he's the mayor like how could
that translate how could this sort of
equity in education translate into
policy well he's also not really into
policing he's sort of down with Riot and
looting things of that nature here he is
in 2020.
there was rioting and organized looting
last night and you're calling to defund
the police explain that
yeah what we're seeing is obviously is
uh an outbreak of incredible frustration
um and anguish that communities that
have been isolated through poverty over
generations and what we have is
um sort of a typical very standard quite
frankly a very tired response
um to the regularly scheduled pandemic
which is structural racism and that
response has been to increase
um police presence that has not led to
anything of substance to secure
communities and to make communities
whole
such nonsense do you know study after
study has proven that when you send more
policing into these areas these high
crime areas that crime goes down and
when you take policing out and you
defund the police people then are upset
because next thing you know oh grandma
got shot could somebody oh there's
nobody around because we defunded the
police
[Music]
thank you